thanks for loving grumpy and stay grumpy
viral sensation grumpy cat
has died Grumpy's family shared the sad
news on her Instagram page revealing
that the seven-year-old feline
passed away from complications of a
recent infection her owners thanked all
of grumpy supporters over the years
writing quote her spirit will continue
to live on through her fans everywhere
you know any any of their bad
experiences of their bad mood - grumpy
face and just kind of vent it a little
bit you know the world first met grumpy
whose real name was tartar sauce back in
2012 my brother put the first picture up
on Reddit and everyone thought it was
photoshopped so we put a video on
YouTube and within 36 hours I had over a
million views after becoming a meme
grumpy went on to become a staple on
Hollywood red carpets got her own madame
tussauds wax figure starred on Broadway
released books ladies and gentlemen
grumpy cat made TV appearances landed
endorsement deals and even starred in
her own Lifetime movie
[Music]